the league is is anticipating that if
there are stadiums that are closed in
areas where there isn't a stay-at-home
order you're gonna have fans
congregating in the parking lots they're
gonna tailgate they're gonna hang out
they're gonna watch the game on TV
they're gonna have a communal experience
we can't get in the stadium we're upset
about that we're coming out here to
tailgate and we're gonna act like it's a
game day and there's gonna be thousands
of people potentially in these parking
lots unless they shut them down and lock
them up but there's gonna be a perimeter
somewhere they can only lock up so much
around a stadium at some point on the
other side of the perimeter fans are
gonna congregate they're gonna bring
their grills they're gonna bring their
beer they're gonna bring their TVs
they're gonna dress like they would on
game day and they're gonna be close
enough where they at least know that's
where it's happening and we want to be
in there and my point is this if you're
in a community where that's gonna be
allowed outside of the stadium why the
hell aren't you just letting them in if
they're gonna be outside anyway if
they're gonna be mingling outside anyway
and again I'm thinking of images that
we've seen this week one in Arizona one
in Oklahoma where a let them in hey let
him sit next to each other without masks
on hey what the hell let's do it
that's what I can't make sense of that
if that's right and they're all gonna be
outside anyway
why would just just let them in I I mean
I agree with you do let them in yeah
you're right there's it seems like
there's gonna be certain states and
counties and things like that that are
gonna have no restrictions and we're
certainly seeing like you said there's
certain states where the people just
don't seem to give a damn you know and
and and hey listen even up here
in the New York City area they're still
being strict but you still watch the
news at night in New York City and
people are still getting too close to
each other as well to where it's a
little uncomfortable but III mean Mike
I'm with you if you're gonna let them be
outside in the parking lot and be close
together anyways just let him come in
and cheer the big thing is yeah don't
let them too close to the players or the
coaches or anything like that because
maybe they're not comfortable with that
situation and really honestly I thought
I was gonna hear more than six to eight
rows blocked off I thought you might
hear the first 15 to 20 rows really
honestly in this type of situation
but but nonetheless it makes a lot of
sense from the NFL it's gonna be
different looking at these games this
year that's for sure but what we see on
TV but you know there's a part of me
that's somewhat excited to see what its
gonna look like and watch these guys
play in this environment there's a part
of me that's anxious as to whether or
not we're gonna get to see it and I hope
the hell we do one other thing I'm
actually talked about this earlier the
the idea that the league firmly believes
based upon what it has learned about the
virus that outdoor activities are more
or less likely I was trying to find a
way out of those weeds no are less
likely less likely to spread the virus
because the droplets get into the air if
you're in a confined space that's how
the droplets hang around long enough for
other people to get them in their eyes
or their noses outdoors the thinking is
you're you're safer you're at less risk
like in in the states where the spikes
are happening they think the spikes are
happening because it's too hot to be
outside so people are doing things
indoors in the air-conditioning with
poor ventilation and that's how they're
getting it they're learning more and
more about how you don't get it off
everybody was you know worried about
servers you got to wipe everything down
you bring your stuff home from the
grocery store you got to wipe it down
you get your mail you we used to leave
all of our stuff out on the porch for 24
hours right leni virus on it died right
it's all the droplets now that's the
focal point and the thinking is that if
you're outside you're okay and and and
the one data point that people in the
league are paying attention to the
protests there has been no dramatic
spike in the areas where there were
protests several weeks ago now right
people were wearing masks god forbid you
wear a mask
they were outside they weren't social
distancing but they were outside they
had masks on and those did not become
super spreader events meanwhile people
are going to be waiting and watching to
see if a certain event that happened in
Tulsa on Saturday and a certain event
that happened on Phoenix on Tuesday
become super spreader events because it
happened inside without people wearing
masks so the NFL thinks it's on the
right side of this crew
and I'm telling you if there aren't
stay-at-home orders in place in the
cities the counties the states where
stadiums are and you know that people
are gonna show up anyway and they're
gonna be upset that they can't get in
and you may have more fights
you know you fights out in the parking
lot you don't have security out there
per se I just think you just just let
them in if they're gonna be there anyway
and they're gonna be engaging a behavior
that potentially spreads the virus why
not let them in it's that simple yeah
Mike I mean I hear you everything you
said makes you know total sense there's
no doubt about that I guess the thing
that can't kind of came to my brain
though just within this and you know I
know you know people in the NFL and know
things here but the inside conversation
is interesting if that you know
continues to be true and what we're
seeing and the evidence and all that
will that throw a wrinkle in the NFL's
plans as far as the indoor teams Mike
will that make them change anything well
the teams that have a dome automatically
maybe just be like no you know we're not
even gonna risk it being inside you're
not allowed to come in this stadium
whatever it may be I mean I know that's
a huge area still I just wonder if that
will be in the thought process yeah you
know and I think that that makes sense
now the domes the the ceilings are high
enough yeah it's not like being in a
confined space but right you got to
wonder about the circulation you got to
wonder about the air and and and also
and and and see I don't know what's
really going on behind the curtain and
the NFL hasn't been trying all that hard
to let people know what's going on
behind the curtain of the Vikings and
you play in a dump and the University of
Minnesota has its field that you used
for three seasons while your dome was
being built do you just play your games
there this year with fans or do you play
in your home stadium without fans
they're probably gonna stay in their
home stadium without fans or with
reduced fans but I think that's part of
the conversation too if they're
convinced that open air is better and if
there's a concern that being in a domed
stadium increases that risk of the of
the congregation of the droplets and the
infected material ultimately ending up
in other people's eyes and nose it's a
it's I
we're not that long away from July 28
and I remember saying back when we were
in our early days of this you know we
got free agency then we got the draft
but the problem is on the other side of
the draft you have May and May becomes
June and June becomes your ly and July
becomes football and it all goes much
faster before the days and weeks start
to roll by like in those those weeks
before Memorial Day weekend there's this
anticipation summer's coming once it's
once it's more of a weekend man I mean
that role and yeah and here we are here
we are a month since Memorial Day
weekend and I feel no greater clarity
coming from the league other than yeah
we still intend to go forward on July
28th well a few weeks ago you intended
to go forward with a Hall of Fame Game
two and how that turned out so that I
really do think it's incumbent on the
league to get to get some clarity out
there so people I know they don't over
promise but I just think you know we see
these developments and we see what's
going on I think a lot of people are
like I don't know how they can be
football this year I mean you know just
you know just the friends I have around
the NFL and things like that
I think it's 50/50 when I talk to them
you know people coaches front office
people on texting and things like that
just casually you know this time of the
year I think it's probably split down
the middle between all the the
acquaintances I have something yeah
we're gonna find to get a way to you
know get they'll find a way to get it
done we're gonna have some games for
sure you know I don't know it'll be a
full season and then I have other coach
friends you just think there's no way
we're playing football and that you know
they're gonna try and they'll do their
best effort but realistically they don't
think it's gonna happen so you know if
that doesn't tell you where we're at as
a society as a league everything the
people involved in the league or split
down the middle and don't even really
know what to expect at this point
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports